hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
it is groundwork of the metaphysics of
morals Immanuel Kant at a certain point
is going to give us a rather schematic
treatment of what he is calling these
three modes of presenting the principle
of morality the the principle that we've
essentially been looking for is the the
core the touchstone for ethics or for
moral theory itself and he says these
three different ways of presenting it
are indeed interconnected each of them
it it involves or includes we might even
say in a certain respect implies the
other two they lead to each other that
in fact is what he's carrying out in his
analysis in the groundwork and another
thing that he says is although they are
different they really are subjectively
rather than objectively different one
way in which it's framed is that these
are the difference is subjectively
rather than objectively practical what
is the the idea there it's to bring an
idea of reason something that that human
rationality is able to understand closer
to what Kant calls intuition closer to
our grasping it and he says we do this
by way of a certain analogy now he
doesn't explain exactly what he means by
analogy there and that's something very
ripe for for discussion but what we want
to focus on are these three different
ways of looking at the same basic thing
and you notice that these are going to
correspond to the three formulations or
the three ways of understanding the
categorical imperative discussed here in
the groundwork and he tells us that we
have a for every Maxim for every every
rule that we give ourselves by which we
would determine our
own will every every rule for deciding
you might say by which we explain it or
justify it to ourselves or could it
count to another person for what it is
that we're doing and why we're doing it
it has a form it has a matter and then
if you have something that is a little
bit more difficult to translate a
complete determination is a great way of
translating it whole standing abashed
among in in German there's other there's
other ways in which this does get
translated for example complete
characterization there's there's a
variety of ways but still means these
things are connected with each other and
they are made you know in some respect
they're made concrete they're made
relational the you know determination I
think is the best word for capturing it
now what does that mean so if we take
any sort of Maxim I you know when a
situation is like this then I will
behave in this way whenever I have this
motive and I'm in this sort of case I
will do this
what Conte is saying is that it has a
form and the form is its universality
and this is the universality of what
this is that that first formulation of
the categorical imperative I'll act
always on the maxim notice Maxim that
you can at the same time will to be a
universal law of nature now it may not
actually be a universal law of nature
but you should be able to will that that
the world could actually look like what
it would be if everybody behaved the
same way as you and if everybody had to
behave the same way as you why is it the
form well because that tells us how
indeed we want to be acting what is what
is the thing that connects them all
together my actions and other people's
actions I'm not actually saying
everybody will act like me but I will in
such a way that that form could be sort
of you transposed onto everything else
then we have a matter and that matter is
the end and
and is an end in itself here we have the
second formulation of the categorical
imperative right act always in such a
way that you you know treat humanity
never is a mere means but always as an
end in itself treat humanity in yourself
in another people right so that is is a
central to it as well and now we're
starting to get a little bit more
concrete this is why sometimes people
find it easier to make sense out of that
formulation the second formulation of
the categorical imperative then the
first formulation it all depends on how
you're looking at it then we get to the
really interesting one here we don't
have a thing that corresponds to a
universality or end right
the complete determination as Kant is
going to tell us complete determination
of all Maxim's by means of a formula and
the formula is that all Maxim's ought to
by their own legislation by their own
way in which they're they're setting
things down normatively ought to
harmonize with a possible kingdom of
ends as with a kingdom of nature so what
does that mean well we have another
lecture specifically just on that third
formulation but the idea is that now
this goes beyond simply saying well
whatever I happen to do it should be a
universal law of nature if they can't
meet that test and I shouldn't do that
sort of thing right or I have if I want
to claim that what I'm doing actually is
in accordance with duty it has to be
universally applicable to everybody or
but I'm treating everybody else as as an
end or not treating myself as a mere
means either here we're bringing the two
together and there's a kind of you might
even say synthesis taking place here now
Kant will go on and say by the way this
connects up with my way of
looking at categories of quantity you
know that he's discussed in other other
works and he's going to be talking about
in the Katif that this is you know sort
of leading towards he says here we go
there's a progress here in the order of
the categories of something right of the
form of the will right the unity of the
form of the will no longer just the
maximum the unity einheit choosing
something that is coherent that can be a
unity that can be applied in every
single case the same way plurality
plurality of the matter of the will what
do we tell I is it plurality feel height
in German here because we're already
look looking at ends and means right we
have a plurality but we can also think
about self and other right humanity in
myself humanity in the other person
there there a variety of ways in which I
could treat somebody myself or the other
as a means rather than as an ends then
we have when can't hear calls totality
and actually he says all height odor
totally Tet in the German text right we
could call it the epithet is just a you
know a cognate right of totality all
height you know everything the entirety
right and that is a little bit more
complex right he says here we go the
totality of the system of these so
totality encompasses these two and what
we see is that the thereby the third
formulation of the categorical
imperative or the third mode of
presentation
the principle of morality is in a
certain way the one that encompasses the
other two and brings them together this
is very important because remember the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
is not by itself constant higher ethics
but it's supposed to be a preparation a
groundwork right for the actual
metaphysics of morals which has two
parts one is the you know doctrine of
virtue and the other is the doctrine of
justice which has to do with the
totality of actual human societies and
how legislation want to take place in
those so what we have here is sort of an
interesting schematic way of presenting
the three modes of presentation of the
same one thing the principle of morality
the three different formulations the
three different ways of looking at it as
Kant said from the beginning as they
want to reiterate each of these does
involve the other this is really about
you know finding the best way of
presenting our understanding of duty and
of autonomy to particular people so some
people may pick up on one better than
they pick up on another at least for a
certain time generally I find most
people pick up on the second one better
than the first let alone the third but
these these provide us with ways to get
at what morality is according to Kant